and a 617 830 for 750 is the number name
and town we are taking post-election
calls getting your thoughts who's on
with me next hello hey uh name in town
were you calling from sure I'm Christian
I'm from Exeter New Hampshire cool
what's on your mind today so I've been
talking with a lot of my teachers am
currently in high school um and you know
a lot of them have been blaming the
voters that they didn't get out to vote
right and in my mind as an avid Bernie
supporter I'm thinking well you know
maybe Bernie would have been a better
general election candidate mmm but they
say no the the Republicans would have
Kingdom as a socialist I was wondering
um how i guess- would have that uh
description bin I mean I think kolinsky
from secular talk talk a little bit
about it how basically Bernie tell
himself as a socialist right and he let
barely see that being too negative but I
was wondering what your take with it was
I tend to agree with that and there's
sort of two two thoughts on that number
one Americans are the least negative
they've been to the term socialist since
we basically done polling on that so
socialist is is has it the least
negative status in American history
since we've sort of been looking at that
title number two Bernie Sanders had a
very good way of explaining I'm talking
about democratic socialism we still have
private business we still have all of
these things that are better capitalist
economic a per uh you know part of the
the capitalist apparatus but I believe
everybody should have health care
regardless of whether they can afford it
or not I believe that everybody should
have access to education whether or not
they can afford or want to take hundreds
of thousands of loans to go to a good
school so I agree with Kyle that not
only is the socialist label the least
bad it's been for a very long time
Bernie Sanders was not scared of that
and he was able to say listen I'm not a
communist I'm a Democratic Socialist and
here's what that made right now as far
as the difference yesterday patent
Rachel what when we were when we were
looking at the results of this election
we sort of realized that
in many of these states were Trump won
that they were they were not States
historically that the republican wins
wisconsin is a really good example it
was a pretty small margin right i mean
wisconsin we're talking about a one
percentage point margin so if even a
small portion of the electorate went
Trump or stayed home because of the FBI
email stuff for example the other areas
in which Hillary Clinton was a
controversial and arguably flawed
candidate then yep Bernie Sanders may
have been able to take that state so I
think that there is a lot to that but
we'll never altima tlie know for sure
will we know well I mean we'll never
know for sure but I also feel like the
bigger issue here is that I think he and
I voted for him I really I'm very
ideologically aligned with him but I
really feel like he did not come out
with enough support for Hillary Clinton
I feel like he could have done a lot
more to kind of revolutionize all of the
Bernie or bust people and maybe the
margins would have been a little bit
smaller that's a fair point Pat well you
saw this race was really lost by Hillary
Clinton in the Rust Belt right yeah
Pennsylvania Michigan Wisconsin and
you'd have to think that Bernie Sanders
would have turned out more union support
and a lot of people voted against
Hillary Clinton cuz they thought NAFTA
in the extension of Bill Clinton's
policies to continue and I don't think
we would have saw that under Bernie
you're right in that it had she won
Pennsylvania and you know Ohio is part
of that too and then you've got
Wisconsin and then then you see you know
everything also Iowa as well Florida
where she lost would have basically
become irrelevant at least electoral II
so I think there's a lot to that uh
thanks so much for the call i really
appreciate it thank you alright